[Musique]
c'est un grand classique des campagnes
électorales
aujourd'hui c'est le député sortant de
Sainte-Rose qui a l'honneur d'animer le
bingo le G53 mais le 3 octobre ce sont
trois autres lettres qui l'espèrent voir
sortir du lot à Laval le C le a et le Q
Lavalle souvent été concentré rouge là
on a goûté un peu à qu'est-ce que ça
peut ressembler un parti bleu pâle donc
on se dit je pense qu'on est prête à ça
puis je pense que il y a un peu
d'ouverture un peu plus d'ouverture
qu'avant 2018
circonscription ayant été remporté par
le Parti libéral et cette feuille est
charmant
au bingo comme ailleurs dans la ville la
pluie aux troupes de François Legault se
fait clairement sentir
[Musique]
la CAQ travaille très fort mais aussi
peut-être que ces résultats-là sont
aussi un peu causés par l'effondrement
du Parti libéral on vous souhaite
toujours la bonne chance puis courage ça
roule polo est le seul député libéral
sortant qui se lissait un nouveau mandat
à Laval face à une réélection qui est
loin d'être assurée il répond à voir
l'habitude de l'adversité que ce soit en
2014 quand j'ai affronté les au bureau
de loin ou que ce soit en 2018 lorsque
j'ai affronté la vague kakis cette
élection ne fait pas ne fait pas
exception et pour faire mentir ce qu'il
appelle les prophètes de malheur dans
une ville où la proportion de nouveaux
arrivants a rapidement augmenter il mise
sur le message d'inclusion du Parti
libéral on ne sent aucune tension ou
questionnement face cette diversité face
à de la nouvelle immigration et c'est là
que beaucoup de la Valois ne se
reconnaissent pas dans le discours de
monsieur Legault c'est crainte face à
l'immigration fornite and the side c'est
un récit devrait quand même rester
fidèle au libéraux qui pourront aussi
compter sur de nouveaux appuis qu'est-ce
qui vous ferez votre libéral cette
fois-ci
un vote de position
mais les autres parties séduisent aussi
je vais vous dire
l'environnement toutes les valeurs qui
véhiculent pourquoi
solidaires et conservateurs refusent
d'ailleurs de s'avouer vaincu on sent
vraiment une vague péquiste les gens
aiment notre chef honnêtement pas le
fait une tellement bonne campagne
qu'avec soldat est connu pour toujours
avoir fait des belles surprises en 2018
on a réussi à envoyer 10 députés
solidaires car madame Anglade était
récemment dans une fête italienne je
pense que je distribue plus mes cartes
d'affaires que son équipe y compris
l'équipe de la CAQ votre niveau de
confiance pour le 3 octobre se situe ou
présentement moi mon niveau de plutôt
dire mon niveau de confiance et mon
niveau de motivation dit je suis
américaine élection j'en ai perdu deux
avant j'en ai gagné une alors pour moi
on prend pas ces choses là à la légère
les députés sortants préférés se
montrent et prudents dans l'attente de
l'annonce des gagnants de 15 dollars
félicitations ici Mathieu papillon
Radio-Canada Laval